GAME SIX WITH THE GAME ON THE E
CHANCE, BUT THEY WENT FOR THE
CHANGE ANYWAY, ANDA SHOT ON GOA
IS SPINNING AROUND, ANIGHT
ALONG THE BLUE LINE,T GOAL A FEO
AS HARTMAN GOING T KAPRIZOV WIT
ZUCCARELLOE PATIENCE THERE FOR
OF THE FIRST BACK, AS LEDDY
PO
THAT IS LEFT BY THE LEG PAD OF
TO PREVENT THA
AND DUMBA LOST IT, AND FELL DOWN
AND GAVE I AND HE IS SEEING
FORWARD IS SPURGEON, AND HE OT
COULDN'T GET THERE AND
SERIES HE IS PLAYING IN PLACE OF
MARC-ANDRE FLEURY.  PLAY AS
LUKE SCHENN IS GOING TO GET DOWS
BLUES GO RIGHT TO WORK ON THE
POWER PLAY.
>> Butch: NICE EFFORT BYS WAY F
ALEXEIA BEAUTIFUL
PLAY B
PERUNOVICH, PERRON, AND PLAYING
CATCH.
DAVID PERRON
THAT CHANCE THAT MINNESOTA HAD
NEEDS TO DO MORE, BUT CREDIT TE
ZUCCARELLO LOOKING TOWARDS THE
NET.
LEAVES IS SURVIVED THA AND BIG
REBOUND, AND BARBASHEV IS GOING
TO MOVE IT TK UNDERNEATH
HIM.RSESHOES GOING FOR
HIM, BUT HE IS VERY GOOD OUTHEA.
HE JUST GOT IT AND TOOK A LOOK,
AND THIS I I